bienvenue dans ac connecte le long
chemin de la réconciliation nationale
depuis deux décennies en côte d'ivoire
au moins avec l'acquittement d'une
figure emblématique de la scène
politique ivoirienne laurent gbagbo
notamment le processus est il sur le
point de se concrétiser on va en parler
et se connecter avec un autre invité ou
le shérif balle est président
d'alternative citoyenne ivoirienne une
association de la société civile proche
de l'opposition bonjour à vous paul
cherry balle est vous êtes à abidjan en
côte d'ivoire merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans afrique connecte
au moment des manifestations
préélectorales vous avez été arrêté dans
la nuit du 15 au 16 août 2020 pour avoir
appelé à des manifestations pacifiques
contre le troisième mandat contestée
d'alassane ouattara des hommes cagoulés
sont venus me chercher alors que vous
étiez cachez vous avez passé huit mois
en détention avant d'être libéré en
avril 2021 est ce que vous considérez
avec le recul que votre arrestation en
tant que personnalité de la société
civile était et reste un affront au
processus de réconciliation nationale
mon arrestation
n'a pas véritablement
de lien avec le processus de
réconciliation puisque nous contestions
la violation de la constitution
il s'agissait de réclamer l'état de
droit maintenant
c'est évident que si on veut parler de
réconciliation il faut
prendre des dispositions pour qu'on ait
plus de prisonniers politiques de ce
point de vue là l'arrestation peut être
niée au processus de réconciliation
puisqu'il ya encore des prisonniers
politiques qu'il faut libérer absolument
si on veut la réconciliation en côte
d'ivoire
comment s'est déroulée votre détention
et quelle leçon vous en tirer
puis la détention s'est relativement
bien passé parce que on n'est jamais
heureux d'être privés de liberté mais en
même temps ça a été le lieu de faire le
point de la lutte ça a été le mieux de
formation ça a été le mieux de
l'obstruction et donc on peut dire que
d'une façon générale la détention s'est
bien passé ça veut dire que quand vous
dites que c'est un lieu de formation
vous étiez en lien toujours avec votre
entourage
pour échanger discuter
de là bas on suivait quand même ce qui
se passait à l'extérieur on était un
lien aussi avec certaines personnes ça
nous permettait de prendre du recul
vis-à-vis de tout ce qui se passe et
d'en tirer les leçons qu'il faut
alors justement est-ce que la
réconciliation nationale elle est en
marche en côte d'ivoire réconciliation
politique mais aussi réconciliation des
communautés
en réalité la réconciliation n'est pas
véritablement annoncé il y a eu
plusieurs initiatives du gouvernement en
faveur de la réconciliation
mais étant donné que cette initiative
n'était pas élu elles n'ont pas donné
la preuve aujourd'hui encore il existe
beaucoup de divisions tant au niveau des
politiques qu'au niveau des communautés
donc on peut dire que la réconciliation
n'est pas véritablement à mons et il
faut absolument engager un dialogue
franc autour de la réconciliation
véritablement la déclencher ou
mettre le processus en marche
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a eu aucune
évolution
durant cette dernière décennie
aucune évolution c'est trop dire mais il
n'y a pas eu
de
combat dit il n'y a pas eu de
d'initiative déterminante le président
de la république a initié la cdvr qui a
fait un diagnostic qu'a fait l'état des
lieux qui a fait l'inventaire des
victimes ensuite il ya eu là qu'on
n'arrive qui était essentielle des
musées la victime mais cela n'a pas été
équitable
après il ya eu le programme national de
cohésion sociale qui en tout cas eu
plusieurs autres initiatives mais le
châtel que les victimes se plaignent
toujours le fait est que sur le terrain
les divisions existent toujours le fait
est que le climat politique n'est pas
encore véritablement apaisé donc on peut
dire que
l'essentiel n'a pas encore été fait la
sévère que vous avez évoquées on va en
parler tout à l'heure il s'agit de la
commission vérité-réconciliation
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour le shérif
balette vous oeuvrer en faveur de cette
réconciliation nationale on va aussi en
parler d'un enjeu capital pour l'avenir
et la cohésion sociale en côte d'ivoire
et pour cause les années de guerre
civile de conflits politiques et
électoraux ont fracturé à la société
ivoirienne illustration dans ce
reportage de lit la femme ouzou qui a
rencontré deux ivoiriens l'un à voter
pour laurent gbagbo en 2010 et l'autre
pour alassane ouattara
nous sommes ici à abobo bastion
d'alassane ouattara et nous partons à la
rencontre de khalifa un jeune homme de
34 ans partisans du président ivoirien
depuis toujours khalifa a commencé à
s'intéresser à la politique alors qu'il
était encore au lycée féru d'économies
le parcours d'alassane ouattara le
fascine il m'a fait travailler des plus
que l'était à la famille aulas c'est
mieux que nous que j'affectionne depuis
longtemps au début des années 90 dans un
contexte de crise économique et
communautaire le président henri
konan-bédié et une partie de la classe
politique ivoirienne décide de se servir
du concept nationaliste d' ivoirité pour
freiner l'ascension d'alassane ouattara
originaire du nord du pays il est accusé
d'avoir des origines burkinabé et voix à
deux reprises ses ambitions politiques
s'arrêter aux portes de la présidence de
la république
cette stratégie des responsables
politiques de l'époque va accentuer les
tensions communautaires et conduire le
pays à la guerre civile au tournant des
années 2000 les gens de l'ouest ont
tendance à croire que les noirs dit sont
pas des vrais ivoiriens la pseudo
liberté y est toujours et les ivoiriens
qui sont au nord 60 formant les et 60
mis à l'écart au fait la période
d'instabilité politique va atteindre son
paroxysme avec l'élection présidentielle
de 2010 qui voit le pays se déchire et
une nouvelle fois entre les pro ouattara
et les pro gbagbo le 16 décembre 2010
khalifa participent à une manifestation
devant le siège de la télévision
nationale ivoirienne lorsqu'il est
confronté à l'impensable et gèle mamika
repos une balle sous mes yeux ont pas
révèle à un pays vont s'atteler de part
et d'autre les gènes d'un déplacement
moi qui a pris une balle
succombé à ses blessures plus de 3000
ivoiriens ont perdu la vie lors de la
crise post électorale de 2010 2011 une
période qui va mettre à mal les
relations entre khalifa et l'un de ses
amis d'enfance landry qui a toujours
affiché sa proximité avec le combat
debout on est très proches avant mais ça
fait que
la discute on fait que y'a chacun a vécu
les un peu de pub bien le connaître mais
on n'a donné qu' à t-il il a des amis
j'ai des amis en dehors de nous deux tu
vois donc c'est pas plutôt chouette
londres y vit également à abobo en
minorité dans ce quartier
majoritairement pro-ouattara il s'est
senti en danger pendant la crise moi je
t'adresse à quelqu'un que tu connais pas
tu sais pas à qui tu as fait il sait pas
si c'est un promoteur a donc tu dois
majorité des cas le fait avec beaucoup
de tension ça traite de partout c'était
tellement l'as cozes et quand on sortait
on voyait des tasses des balles passées
par l'envoyé d'être adav en modules qui
méritait c'était le chaos et on a vu des
personnes utiles qu'ils ont pris des
éclats d'obus est à la maison il aura
fallu des années pour que les plaies
cicatrisent c'est que les deux hommes ce
retard ya madame idiart est prévue en
2018 je suis pas tiens matin préparer à
sa porte il a ouvert la porte et il m'a
vu
il n'a pas vu par rapport à l'actrice
les cinq entités méfier du mois je suis
venu on met un squeeze et ses moyens
puisque le suivi de m'accuser et j'ai vu
que j'avais pas comme avant il m'avait
vu on a mangé ngaba et tout s'est bien
passé grâce à du aujourd'hui on peut
coiffer une semaine son choix tant moi
j'étais encore au collège quand je
quitte à l'école j'y suis avec lui on
papa temps semble jouer au football
ensemble et quand on voit que des
tirettes pour l'éthique une s'inscrivent
qui s'éclate je n'aimerais pas que nos
caisses assez répété en profite parce
que de la tenue tu paie une partie des
toffees le retour de laurent gbagbo en
côte d'ivoire a fait craindre une
résurgence des tensions mais cette fois
ci les deux amis ont préféré prendre les
choses avec humour
moi je t'aimerai prêtre très bon gta
comptant jusqu'à hier dans ces mêmes ce
jour là je sèche et soutiennent je
l'invitais mais il dit si ce n'était pas
bien sûr un abattement boîte même à
l'évolution des recettes nous narguer
cet esprit au bouquet collabos tous sont
arrivés tout le monde savait que ça
allait être un truc où il y allait avoir
de l'ambiance il fallait s'y attendre
c'est comme si on ne prenait pas en
compte la souffrance de ceux qui ont
perdu des proches ont demandé aux
acteurs politiques de mettre un peu
d'eau dans le vin est d'amener la
population à les suivre
son délit des politiques ce sont des
aides des grands hommes d'état
le parole et puis le hat va va permettre
à la côte d'ivoire de vaumas aller vers
la réconciliation vraie on ne veut pas
une consultation des façades obtenir une
reconnaissance du statut des victimes
permettre une indemnisation des familles
ou encore instaurer un véritable
dialogue national
c'est ce que demandent les ivoiriens
aujourd'hui pour faire toute la lumière
sur cette période sombre de leur
histoire et pouvoir enfin se tourner
vers l'avenir
ces deux jeunes ivoiriens il évoque
également le retour de laurent gbagbo un
retour dont la plupart à des médias
internationaux et même fait les
partisans politique de laurent gbagbo en
ont fait une clé de la réconciliation à
tort ou à raison selon vous
comme vous avez vu dans le reportage il
a été très bien réalisé effectivement
les populations ont soif de conciliation
et le blocage véritable se situe au
niveau des hommes politiques parce que
plusieurs de ces populations se
reconnaissent dans ces hommes politiques
et ils attendent que ce soit eux qui
donnent l'exemple
lorsque le président gbagbo a rencontré
le président alassane cela appuyé une
passion au niveau des populations
donc nous croyons si les politiques qui
font l'effort de s'engager dans la
réconciliation
la population souffre parce que
plusieurs populations se reconnaissent
en chacun d'entre vous le shérif balle
est on va marquer une courte pause et
poursuivre dans un instant on se
retrouve tout de suite restez avec nous
sur rt france
un retour dans afrique honnête nous
sommes avec paul cherry balle est
président d'alternative citoyenne
ivoirienne
une association de la société civile en
côte d'ivoire et on évoque avec elle le
processus de réconciliation nationale
paul cherry balle est on va écouter tout
de suite une activiste social
en boulet diallo kadiatou camara
tout ce qui est mêlée à la politique
touche qu'il est moins les personnes les
personnes victimes aujourd'hui quand je
prends le cas spécifique de mon pays la
guinée et à combien
d'années on a commencé à mettre en place
cette histoire de réconciliation de
chervey puisque il y avait toujours des
violences étaient à des personnes
frustrées quand vous parlez de la
réconciliation il vous regarde d'abord
donc je pense que l'instrumentalisation
de cette histoire de
2,2 comment je veux dire de la
conciliation nationale des safer
seulement sa mise en place et ça met en
danger sa réussite au fait
mon chéri balette l'instrumentalisation
des processus de réconciliation
nationale par les politiques qu'est ce
que vous dites à ce niveau et comment
l'éviter
c'est vrai que les processus de
réconciliation sont instrumentalisés
parce que la bonne choix des politiques
n'est pas à gérer en ce qui concerne ce
qui se passe en côte d'ivoire nous
entendons les politiques de tous les
bords parler de réconciliation
mais parallèlement chacun pose des actes
ou dit des choses qui vont à l'encontre
de cette réconciliation et aucun d'entre
eux ne proposent de
démarches concrètes qu on y aille alors
il ya eu des initiatives avant celle que
vous menez actuellement des gestes aussi
notamment de la part du président
ivoirien alassane ouattara puisqu'il a
amnistié 800 personnes dont simone
gbagbo mais il reste encore une centaine
de personnes qui ont été arrêtées en
2010 2011 selon justement laurent gbagbo
est ce qu'il faut libérer ces personnes
là
vous le disais tout le monde puisque
pouilly m'en libérer toutes ces
personnes bay pour faire en sorte que
tous les exilés en a ce qu'il faut que
tout le monde ait voix au chapitre il
faut que tout le monde se sente concerné
haché et par la réconciliation s'il ya
encore des prisonniers signe encore des
guinness est évident que leurs partisans
ou leurs proches ne seront pas disposés
à s'engager dans ce dialogue la
réconciliation
donc c'est vraiment un préalable pour
que la réconciliation soit effective qu
il n'y est plus depuis zone et politique
qu'il n'y ait plus d'exilés et que nous
puissions nous asseoir ensemble parler
de ce que nous devons faire pour en
sortir et nous avons beaucoup d'espoir
parce que le lancement de la cérémonie
que nous avons fait était d'abord de
couver que l'on pouvait rassembler tous
les ivoiriens et se joue là nous avons
eu tout le monde ce qui n'était pas là
se sont fait représenter et donc nous
avons eu la preuve qu'on peut
effectivement rassembler tout le monde
pense quand vous dites les exilés cela
inclut le clan soro mais aussi charles
blé goudé
qui sont aujourd'hui toujours exilés et
est-ce qu'il faut aussi abandonné les
poursuites judiciaires à leur encontre
et compris à l'encontre de laurent
gbagbo à
l'idéal aurait été qu'on abandonne les
poursuites judiciaires ou la simple
raison ni qui étions sur place pendant
que toutes ces crises se passait savons
que chacun a sa part de responsabilité
dans tout ce qui est en vie ce n'est
donc pas juste en poursuivre cet été et
que ceux qui sont actuellement au
pouvoir ont aussi leur part de
responsabilité soit exemple de push it
est un problème là donc l'idéal aurait
été qu'on abandonne toutes les
poursuites pénales puissions-nous par
les agences situer les responsabilités
nous déciderons ensemble de ce qu'il
faut faire et l'idéal aurait été que
nous nous engagions dans une justice
transitionnelle ça c'est plus apaisant
parce que la justice moderne
après qu'elle a ses limites on a retenu
le président va vaut plus de 10 en deux
ans avec un procès qu'a dû et tout ce
temps là nous n' y être acté mais au
moins on les dédommage par rapport à ce
qu'il a subi et si le résultat était
jugé le risque aussi on a vu que laurent
gbagbo a lancé son parti politique le
retour des exilés
s'ils reviennent un jour en côte
d'ivoire s'ils sont amnistiés peut-être
qu'ils vont reprendre aussi du service
dans le champ politique ivoirien avec le
risque de retrouver ces mêmes rivalité
qui minent finalement le pays depuis des
décennies
oui mais c'est justement pourquoi ce
risque là soient effacés il faut que
only bay tout le monde et il faut qu'on
se parle où trouver un consensus ou
aller à la réconciliation
moi je pense que c'est on se parle et
qu'on s'est pas franchement on arrivera
à désamorcer les crises futures
le shérif balle est on va écouter à
nouveau l'activiste social diallo
kadiatou camara
il faut forcément qu'ils adhèrent 1
qu'ils soient des c'est vrai c'est des
politiciens mais qu'ils soient des
citoyens pour leur peuple qu'ils se
mettent à la place des personnes qui se
mettent à la place des personnes à la
place des problèmes des personnes qu'ils
essayent de faire une lecture général de
qu'est ce qui a poussé les gens à
servent de caisse qui a poussé les gens
à ce problème pour que eux par exemple
qui aspire être au pouvoir un jour
parvenir à trouver des solutions avant
qu'il ne vienne sinon on sera dans une
répétition capture donc je pense qu'ils
doivent jouer un très grand rôle dans
cette histoire de conciliation malgré
son phare au pouvoir mais qu'ils sachent
que temps que cette histoire de le
coincer des situations n'est pas une
vérité dans leurs pays respectifs
ça va être très difficile pour les la
stabilité démocratique dans les pays
[Musique]
le plus chéri bennett c'est vrai en 2010
on s'en souvient de nombreux ivoiriens
exprimer cette crainte face à ces
rivalités
politiques à des violences possibles à
nouveau dans la rue en tout cas il ya un
ras-le-bol qui s'exprimait face aux
agissements de la classe politique
ivoirienne est ce que finalement les
politiques il devrait pas se tenir en
retrait laisser tranquille les
populations et laisser agir la société
civile
bon moi je pense que c'est la diversité
qui est souhaitable on ne devrait pas
mettre les politiques de côté pour que
la société civile sur cette prime mais
il faut que chacun joue son rôle en
respectant l'éthique en respectant le
droit c'est ça qui est le vrai problème
tant que nous serons
dans un état de droit tant que chacun
sera libre d'exprimer ce qu'il veut tant
dans le cadre électoral permettra que le
peuple choisit lui même ses dirigeants
sans qu'il y ait de tricherie les choses
pourront bien se passer le problème le
vrai c'est qu'il n'y a pas des tic dans
le jeu politique c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de transparence dans le jeu électoral
et c'est ça je sais qu'il ya problème
est ce que vous vous savez aussi qu'on
voit les sociétés civiles dans d'autres
pays du continent se soulever face à des
pouvoirs qui s'éternise justement le
souci en côte d'ivoire est ce que ce
n'est pas le fait que parfois les
associations de la société civile sont
apparentés un parti politique par
exemple vous votre association on l'a
dit proche de l'opposition est ce que ce
n'est pas un frein pour mener vos
actions
ce sont des préjugés en réalité chez
nous ici je sais pas comment ça se passe
dans les autres pays africains
mais chez nous en côte d'ivoire les
politiques et jetons utilisent les
populations quand quelqu'un n'est pas
avec vous il est forcément content que
vous ce qui n'est pas vrai notre
association particulièrement des proches
d'aucun parti politique
nous luttons pour les droits nous
luttons pour que coin l'état de droit
pour peu qu'il y ait la bonne
gouvernance et il arrive que nos
positions soit en soit ainsi avec ce que
l'opposition veut et d'autre il ya des
gens qui pensent que nous sommes
manipulés par l'opposition mais pas du
tout nous sommes des adultes qui nous
sommes
des diplômés nous avons une capacité
d'analysé
nous nous réunissons nous analysons le
contexte et nous prenons nos décisions
et nous mettons nos actions donc
je pense que c'est trop facile de dire
que la société civile est ce que
montrent anisé ce qui est vrai c'est que
il n'y pas suffisamment de démocratie
pour que la société civile s'exprimant
temps par rapport aux organisations que
nous sommes que par rapport aux
suffrages et les populations
notre combat on veut la liberté
d'expression on veut pouvoir être libre
de dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
et de faire des propositions pour la
société ivoirienne avance et c'est ce
que nous faisons l'autre combat que nous
menons c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est par rapport à la clé 10
minutes et de l'eau donc ils ne sont pas
instrumentalisés travaillons
en côte d'ivoire il ya on vous l'avait
évoqué tout à l'heure il ya une
commission vérité justice qui a été
instaurée justement pour tenter de
réconcilier les ivoiriens elle a
longtemps était présidée par charles
konan banny qui était décédé d'ailleurs
en septembre de cette année 2021 une
commission qui affiche un bilan très
mitigé comment vous l'expliquez c'est
trop lourd compliqué pas assez inclusif
il ya un manque de moyens
non c'est une question de volonté
politique
c'est bien que cette commission a été
mise sur pied par
le problème c'est que les
recommandations de cette commission
n'ont pas été entièrement mises en
oeuvre c'est ça qui a été le véritable
problème sinon la commission a bien
travaillé mais ces résultats n'ont pas
été exploitées ensuite là qu'on arrive a
été mise en place mais seulement pour
les indemnisations et là encore les
victimes de tous les bords se plaignent
de n'avoir pas été prises en compte donc
nous pensons que le vrai problème c'est
le caractère non exclusif de tout ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à présent et la
reconnaissance des victimes leur
dédommagement où en est on
bon déjà je voudrais qu'on est le point
des victimes la victime elle-même se
plaignent d'être des laissés pour compte
et nous pensons que c'est vrai parce
qu'il ya eu plusieurs crises dont il ya
plusieurs catégories de victimes
certaines sont privés j'ai par rapport à
d'autres et le débat sur la victime n'a
vraiment pas on pense véritablement eu
lieu donc il ya lieu même de fait un
point la victime qui est victime qui ne
l'est pas qu'est-ce qu'on fait ou les
dédommager et la question reste encore
posée
pour terminer pour chery balle est après
2010 il y avait deux camps celui des
vainqueurs et des vaincus est-ce que la
situation s'est quand même amélioré à ce
niveau oui
bon il ya une décrispation la preuve
c'est que le président laurent gbagbo
est monté mais on ne peut pas dire
que la situation s'est grandement
améliorée nous avons encore le mini
charles blé goudé qui n'est pas encore
en fait nous avons le président soro
guillaume qui est menacé de tout pas
nous avons encore des exilés qui ne sont
pas rentrés et même ceux qui sont
montrés la situation n'est pas gérée de
façon équitable il ya une injustice dans
la façon dont on traite les exilés qui
sont venus dont il ya encore beaucoup de
questions en suspens et jetons qu' on ne
peut pas dire et le processus soit la
paix la situation et est véritable
vous faites confiance à la justice
ivoirienne
personnellement je ne lui fait pas
confiance sinon je ne serais pas
allé en prison mais ce qu'on doit dire
c'est que les gens fassent la différence
entre la culpabilité et la
responsabilité
en tête de pipe habilité et à la justice
de faire la part des choses mais en
termes de reste pour sa bonne idée
chacun a sa part de responsabilité et
ils sont et chacun le reconnaît ce ne
serait ce que pour apaiser les victimes
et s'engager dans un dialogue
constructif pour que ensemble nous
puissions changer la meilleure démarche
voile est effectivement à la
réconciliation
merci beaucoup à vous plus chéri banet
merci beaucoup
et merci à aux équipes du mag et
techniques merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis retrouver afrique honnête sur nos
réseaux sociaux et notre site internet
rt france point tv à très bientôt sur
arte france